you're watching the daily climate show
on Sky News coming up on today's program
a warning the climate crisis is making
the housing emergency worse as extreme
weather events become more common
flying taxis alternative protein and
fusion power the uk-based sustainable
startups encouraging a record level of
investment
and restoring wildlife habitats and
cutting carbon emissions The Pact
covering more than a third of England's
land to tackle the climate and nature
crises
foreign
to the UK's only daily climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now and challenge those
coming up with the solutions
now we're starting this evening with a
warning that those who are homeless and
in poor housing are at increasing risk
from the climate crisis according to
three leading Charities that's because
those are sleeping rough are more
affected by extreme weather events such
as flooding and heat waves while the
growing cost of energy means that some
are having to choose between heating
their homes or paying their rent well
let's get more on this now with Alistair
Harper who's head of public affairs at
the housing charity shelter good evening
to you Alistair Harper so tell us just
how serious is this situation how is
climate change affecting homeless people
in this country right now
well unfortunately what we're seeing
right now is that the climate
emergencies here it's uh we're on the
front line the front line is our front
door and
um what the reality means is that
the climate matches come hand in hand
with the pre-existing housing emergency
where the homes that we have for far too
many in this country are just not
adequately equipped as it stands to keep
warming to keep dry and keep safe in
um costs are spiraling of fossil fuel
energy costs and that's before we factor
in these extreme weathers events that
we've been seeing over the last year
um it's frustrating because we knew that
this would come uh our allies in the
global self warned that these extreme
events have been what they've been
experiencing for a very long time and
they also warned us that it would be the
most vulnerable that that face the most
pain the people who did the least to
cause this emergency face the most pain
so if you're in a home and it's hard to
keep warm it's it's going to get harder
at present until we we sort out our
buildings and that's if you're fortunate
to have a home for people who are on the
streets um winter is always hard but
we're seeing right now with Arctic blast
like we're facing just how impossible it
is to stay safe in uh it as our climate
deteriorates
the government would say wouldn't they
that they're investing over 12 billion
pounds over the next five years in
affordable housing they also will say
they're spending more than two billion
pounds to tackle rough sleeping and
homelessness so what more do you want
the government to do
well first of all let's take the crisis
right now in front of us of the people
still on the streets this winter facing
this Arctic blast we need clear guidance
from the government that everyone should
be allowed in and looked after by their
councils they face this emergency and
funding to back it
um but in the long term we know this
isn't going away and too many people are
in bad housing too many people are in an
unregulated bloated private rented
sector that is exploiting the people of
this country as it is today never mind
when we we've got extreme weather that
is impossible to manage so we need
government investment in the actual
quality secure safe homes that we need
in this country and that means instead
of losing 20 000 social homes a year we
actually start to build it back and that
for us is actually the opportunity
because we could show what quality safe
housing means by doing a pilot of Net
Zero social housing across every town in
the country give people the sign that
they need that housing can be better can
be more affordable can be safer and show
off the Technologies we need to tackle
the climate emergency
Aleister Harper thanks very much indeed
now let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and
Indonesia is preparing to launch a
carbon tax to help curb emissions and
reach Net Zero by 2060. it means that
companies will be charged one pound 60
for every ton of greenhouse gases
emitted from coal-fired power plants
around 1 million tons of taxable carbon
emissions were emitted in Indonesia
during a trial covering 32 of the fossil
fuel plants
Nissan has announced plans to spend more
than 13 billion pounds on developing
electric vehicles the car manufacturer
which has a major plant in Sunderland
revealed it'll develop 23 new electric
models by 2030. Electric Car Sales
increased by 186 percent in 2020 and
today there are an estimated 300 000
electric vehicles on the road in the UK
and a pact to restore wildlife habitats
and cut carbon emissions has been signed
by landowners and organizations in
England the duchy of Cornwall has
pledged to increase biodiversity across
its Estates
buy it 30 by 2030 and Yorkshire water
will plant a million trees by 2028. the
groups represent more than 10 million
acres of land around a third of England
now UK startup tech companies which
focus on areas including the environment
and sustainable development have raised
more than two billion pounds of
investment so far this year that's
according to the government now that's a
record amount for impact startups which
are companies founded to build solutions
to the United Nations sustainable
development goals including Health
security climate change and energy
scarcity
well the UK is now home to 12 impact
unicorns that's companies worth more
than a billion dollars in value and many
of these are focused on climate and
environment issues all of the tariffs
for octopus energy which is based in
London use 100 green electricity and the
company offers the option to carbon
offset gas use and they're also
investing in renewable energy technology
British vault in blive is working to
accelerate the electrification of
society with sustainable low-carbon
batteries which will mainly help Power
electric vehicles and depop is a
london-based app connecting people to
buy and sell clothes with the aim of
making fashion less wasteful and more
sustainable and vertical Aerospace is
building zero carbon battery-powered
flying taxis to help revolutionize
sustainable Aviation and how we get
around in the future well joining me now
is vertical Aerospace chief executive
and founder Stephen Fitzpatrick so
welcome to you zero carbon battery
powered flying taxis I mean it sounds
like it's something out of a futuristic
film tell us more about them and how
soon we might see them in the air
yes good evening and thanks for having
me so it does really sound quite
futuristic I know when people think
about
um client actually think about flying
cars and cartoons like The Jetsons and
everything being you know decades and
decades into the future
um the wonderful thing about the
technology we're using it's been
developed already over the last few
decades primarily in the um in the car
sector the automotive sector and so
there's already these great industrial
partners and Supply chains ready to be
taken over into Aerospace and so we're
working with some of the UK's leading
manufacturing and Engineering groups and
uh UK consumers and passengers will be
able to fly in these vehicles from 2024
2025 onwards so it sounds like it's you
know very futuristic but actually it's
just a few years away well yeah and
could the technology be used to
transport larger numbers of people I
mean Aviation a big area where we need
to tackle emissions can it be expanded
yeah so we're starting off uh it'll be a
piloted vehicle with four passengers
um and very quickly we're going to see
that capacity increase
um to first aid and then maybe 16 to 20
passengers per vehicle we're working
with battery uh battery powered only
when we launch but very quickly we'll be
moving into a hybrid powertrain in
particular hydrogen is something we're
looking very closely at and these are
technologies that have been developed
today they will be ready in within this
decade
um and the beautiful thing about the EV
toll so there's electric vertical
takeoff and Landing is that you don't
need to travel you know 10 15 20 even 50
miles to go to an airport you're going
to be able to depart and arrive much
closer to your destination so it's going
to transform how we travel around cities
and if you think hs2 as a wonderful
piece of engineering as it is it is a an
enormous expense that we are paying to
create some ground infrastructure to
help bring passengers from London into
Birmingham in just under an hour we're
going to be able to do exactly the same
Journey at about the same cost without
tens and tens of billions of pounds
invested in the railway Network because
we we're we're flying through the sky so
it is really going to transform how we
travel around it's zero carbon as you've
said all electric and as we start to
look in a longer range uh Journeys we're
we're going to start to make it real
inroads into the fossil fuel based
Aerospace sector and so a really
exciting time in in aviation probably
the most exciting time in Aerospace
since the dawn of the jet turbine and
you're also the founder of the Energy
Group OVO aren't you and we've learned
today about this record amount that's
being raised for so-called impact
startups what do you think about the UK
as a place for a green startup is it a
good place to be
uh well I think there's a few things
there first of all I think there is a
real culture
um of uh environmental awareness in the
UK so there's a great backdrop there
there's a great culture of
entrepreneurialism in particular in the
southwest of England where OVO and
vertical are both based near Bristol in
Bristol there's that there's a lot the
big ecosystem there for uh impact
investing or environmental investing but
I think the big challenge that we faced
in the UK is not about environmental
startups we share in in the in the green
or the cleantech space some of the
challenges we have elsewhere in the UK
which is about scaling up
um we have one of the most
entrepreneurial Societies in the world
and you know more startups per million
people in the UK than there are in the
US
we have not historically done a really
good job of creating Global competitors
and scaling those businesses up and so
that's the big Challenge and I think
today's announcement is about companies
that have really made it to scale
um and and behind them they're countless
others uh doing great work and and and
investing in the future so you know I
think the future looks really bright for
the UK in terms of entrepreneurialism
and investing in what is going to be one
of the biggest growth sectors in in in
in in the whole world in the coming
years and decades that's the
decarbonization of our entire economy
and Society so I think Britain's really
well placed for them Stephen Fitzpatrick
interesting to talk to you thanks very
much indeed
thank you
now in the latest of our series of
climate Diaries we're going to hear from
Olivia Sweeney now Olivia runs walking
groups to engage diverse communities in
conversations about climate action and
air pollution here's her story
[Music]
I'm a black and green Ambassador and
that is a program that's Bristol based
that explores the intersection of
climate and racial Justice my project
has been focused on the problem of dirty
f
[Music]
so in the UK and around the world we
have illegal levels of levels of dirty
air and for me I believe it's an issue
of environmental justice
[Music]
so those who contribute the least are
suffering the most and these are
disproportionately members of the
background community
we put black and brown communities
voices at the Forefront because it's
these communities that are
disproportionately affected by climate
change yet unfortunately it's these
communities that have the least power
and agency to affect change
it's about who you see within the
movement Progressive Thunderbird is
great but there's plenty of other young
black and brown climate activists who
are doing great work so it makes you
think whose voice and and whose actions
are more valued by Society
our work helps to tackle climate change
by putting the role of ethnicity Central
to environmental discussions
[Music]
do stay with us coming up after the
break I will be joined by the climate
activist Lori Young and organic farmer
and Deputy president of the national
Farmers Union Stuart Roberts and we're
going to be discussing the role of clean
tech in tackling climate change and
asking what changes Farmers need to be
making in the way that they work
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
was like pulling us out of that little
room
mandatory evacuation you must leave
I'm Greg Milam Sky's U.S correspondent
here in Los Angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those winds strong enough to bend and
twist metal
are you trying to run me over sir Philip
no go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so Philip can you go away
I've seen the Dark Side of America
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of America's opioid cross
[Music]
I've seen heartbreaking human stories
there is a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget
Christchurch has been changed Forever by
what happened here
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
pickup times
[Music]
there'll be a mostly cloudy morning with
rain or drizzle likely heaviest in the
Northwest Southern and Eastern Parts
have the best chance of some brightness
it'll be mild but they'll be quite a
chilly wind
Scotland the far north of England
Ireland and Northern Ireland will turn
wet and windy during the afternoon
although the rain will give way to
showers in the west later there'll be
little change elsewhere
wind and generally unsettled conditions
mean air pollution levels will be low
with the air quality index between 1 and
3.
the air quality report sponsored by
Philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the Daily
climate show on Sky News now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate activist Laura young and organic
farmer and Deputy president of the
national Farmers Union Stuart Roberts so
a very good evening to both of you nice
to see you both and first of all the
government announced today that UK
startups focusing on sustainable
technology have attracted more than two
billion pounds of investment this year
from renewable energy to carbon-free
Flying taxis Innovation is helping drive
that transition to Net Zero but is it
enough uh well let's talk about this
then Laura young a record amount of
money for these so-called impact
startups that's only got to be good news
hasn't it
I think it is really great news that
we're beginning to see so much
investment in sustainable business I
think it's important that we're
beginning to move all sectors towards
this the one thing I worry about though
when we talk about Green Tech is that we
often try and think about how we can
design our way out of the climate crisis
when often we need to also be having a
conversation about less consumption and
actually returning backwards to ways
that are less damaging for the planet I
think some of the businesses that you
mentioned earlier are great I'm wearing
some kind of second-hand fashion so I
know that's one I've benefited from
myself but I do worry when we think
about flying taxis or more electric cars
and more batteries that we maybe miss a
conversation of how we can make things
like public transport more affordable
and accessible because that's just as
important a climate solution as well as
advancing in a technological way and so
I just really hope that some of the
money also goes towards advancing Tech
wise the systems that we already have
and not just thinking about new design
tools solutions that are kind of really
futuristic and fun Stuart Roberts do you
agree with that does there need to be
more of a joined up conversation and
more of a focus on reducing consumption
rather than relying on on new wysitech
ideas
yeah I think no it's a it's a
combination of both and for me I see
some really exciting Technology
Solutions in agriculture whether that be
feed additives that can reduce methane
whether that be methane tractors or
solar-powered robots to weed crops I
think that's all really exciting stuff
but for me it's also about uh not just
looking at Tech to solve this there's a
consumption side as Laura said but it's
also about looking at things like
particularly in agriculture carbon
sequestration so how can we take that
carbon out of the atmosphere through our
soil through our grassland so Tech it
can be exciting uh it could be fun uh
but but equally it's not the sole
solution and but isn't there an issue
Laura of keeping people on side some of
these exciting innovative ideas will
allow people to carry on their lives as
they were before but in a Greener way it
doesn't doesn't technology help them do
that and you've got to keep the public
committed
I would maybe worry that we're really
struggling to actually live the way that
we currently live at a sustainable rate
and I'm not really sure Green Tech will
be the solution for that actually I
would love to see this investment into
ways that we can do things in a more
sustainable way and kind of returning
back to some of the more simpler
Solutions but we can also have some
really fun Tech Solutions within the
systems that we already have instead of
just trying to create new Industries
above the ones that we already have and
I think it's just about shifting that
that mindset and although it might not
be as fun it's still possible and it
still allows for a lot of growth and a
lot of economic growth as well and I'm
just going to remind everyone of what
John Kerry said Stuart he rather
controversially said that 50 of the
reductions we have to make by 2050 or
2045 going to come from Technologies we
don't yet have I mean a lot of people
disputed that figure but do you think
that governments are caught up with this
idea of being over reliant on technology
as well
yeah I think for me it's that about that
balance so I think technology will help
us on that Journey absolutely and I can
see some areas uh in agriculture where
where there will be technology in future
to solve things we don't even know about
it yet but some of it is also about
looking at just how we do things so for
me the classic is the Hedgerow we can
sequester a lot more carbon in our
hedgerows by managing them slightly
different they add to our landscape but
they're maybe not quite as sexy and
exciting as some of the tech but
actually you can have a as big if not
bigger impact
um and and those are some of the areas
we've got to spend equal amounts of
resources and time on I've never thought
of hedgerows as being sexy but thank you
for for raising that possibility in my
mind and we're kind of kind of sticking
with that subject a little bit next
because we heard earlier in the program
about how the National Trust and other
big landowners have signed a pact to
restore wildlife habitats and cut carbon
emissions now the groups represent
around a third of English land so is
there something that almost can get
behind and how does the idea of
improving biodiversity fit in with
Industrial Level agriculture so Stuart
clearly a question of you first of all
and about 70 of land in England is
agricultural isn't it so is this
something you think that farmers can get
behind
well I think it's something that farmers
have already been behind actually when I
go back to our 2014 Net Zero aspiration
for agriculture uh three four years ago
now we started that I worry sometimes
that that we've become one-dimensional
so actually we look at biodiversity or
we look at water quality or we look at
uh carbon and then we'll sort of add
food into it as well for me what Farmers
need to do going forward is deliver all
of those things produce fantastic foods
but also deliver on biodiversity carbon
and everything else we expect
if you're trying to make a profit and
you've got to give over a load of your
land to biodiversity
as I said the key for me is about
actually lots of these areas there's a
sweet spot where by using our resources
more efficiently by thinking about how
we use our land and which bits of land
we use we can absolutely deliver on food
on the environment on biodiversity where
I worry is actually this sort of
wholesale we'll just turn it all over to
Nature we'll import our food from
somewhere else in the world and actually
just export our environmental footprint
British Farmers want to do both those
things and I think is is really exciting
for the future Laura how important are
these nature-based Solutions and do you
feel that farmers are doing enough
I think farmers are doing a lot and you
can see that through the various
different initiatives that they have you
know I'm from Scotland and it's really
fun going all over the country and
seeing the different solutions that
farmers have but I think one of the
important things that we need to do is
also support them support them in both
the education and in the finance for
doing some of these Solutions because
they are the custodians of lots of the
land that we have here in the UK and we
need to be supporting them because we
are also their customers and we really
want to buy food that has been
sustainably made and so we can all be
playing our part alongside them to help
deliver these nature-based solutions for
the land that we call home here in the
UK very briefly do you sometimes feel
like you're painted as the bad guys you
know agriculture responsible for lots of
methane emissions very briefly does that
feel like it to you
too often agriculture scene is the
problem whereas I see it as absolutely
part of the solution to biodiversity to
carbon but also to producing fantastic
food in a fantastic landscape okay
Stuart Roberts Laura young really good
to talk to you both thanks very much for
joining us this evening
and that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show I'll be joined by
Environmental Lawyer Tessa Khan and Mike
furnace Lee one of the country's leading
experts in carbon footprinting do stay
tuned though we've got Sky News Tonight
coming up for you next including covid
booster vaccines are going to be
extended to everyone aged over 18 has
two more cases of the Omicron variant of
covid-19 are detected in England but
that's it from me thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time
thank you
[Music]